everybody sings heavy alright thank you
thank you guys so much
yeah I just want to start by saying that
I made this film hoping that it would
make people kind of think twice before
they give a discouraging look or or we
look or discouraging word to a little
girl that wants to get that monster
truck toy or that little boy that wants
the the dollhouse or the Easy Bake Oven
please make children feel safe to be
themselves from a young age it could
mean a world of difference for their
sense of identity and to the person they
grew up to be this film would not be
possible without the support of so many
people I want to thank my family for
always having my back my mom
Imani avodah my sisters Karen and
Danielle and my dad who was not with us
anymore but I'm pretty sure throwing one
hell of a party up in heaven watching
tonight's ceremony he really loved films
so I imagine he's very happy and proud
that I'm get to make them to Claire
thank you for your constant love and
support for picking me up every single
time I didn't think I could do this for
the snacks and the coffee breaks and the
pep talks I would not be here without
you
thank you to my Ringling family when
structures Heather Thompson Jeremy Kent
or Paul downs James Martin and the rest
of the CA faculty my production manager
Sydney Berman for those life-saving
deadlines and to my peers who are always
there to support and inspire thank you
Anna Gaines word for the gorgeous sound
design and Garth noise daughter for the
beautiful score I also want to thank my
mentors for always offering their wisdom
your own Farkus Kevin Andrus and odd
Hudson Yangon and of course I'd like to
thank the Academy for this unbelievable
honor
I am so humbled to be standing here
today thank you for getting this story
in front of so many eyes that means more
than anything to me I will never forget
the past week and all the incredible
people I've had the privilege of meeting
I left my country about five years ago
and thanks to animation I found that
what I didn't know I was missing from my
life which was a sense of purpose
follow your passion follow your gut and
if you're not in a place in life when
you're where you're absolutely loving
what you're doing man Peck you pack your
bags and go look for that thing that
makes you tick
thank you so much
[Applause]